Mother's Day weekend is this weekend,
so we're so excited to be teaming up
with Jergens Skin Care for a very special segment.
It is special to me.
In honor of their A Mom Is a Mom campaign celebrating
all moms no matter their path to motherhood,
we're chatting mom to mom with someone
who helps make our show look fabulous.
Please welcome someone who's very dear to me.
It's our graphics designer and new mom, Megan Mucci!
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
Congratulations.
We call her the mooch too.
You're so epic and important to the show
and I love you so much.
I love you too.
I'm so happy to see you again.
(audience cheering)
We have missed you so much.
You're back, thank goodness.
And you have a four-month-old daughter, named Selah.
Aw.
And, Oh my God, that's the most beautiful picture.
Well, Jergens celebrates new moms
and moms who have been through it all.
And they've been making people a little more comfortable
for years and in honor of that,
Megan is actually gonna be the interviewer
and ask a few questions to me
which is so weird and fun.
I'm always the one asking questions
and I'm also just excited to see
what you've come up with.
Yes, I've written them down.
All right.
You ready?
It's, take it away, the mooch.
(everybody laughing)
The first one is,
do you ever have an overwhelming need
to not miss a single moment in your kid's life?
For instance, my daughter's laugh happened
in a different room, and I was so bummed
that I wasn't in the same room with her.
Oh, God, that is painful. A laugh-
I heard it, but it wasn't in person, so.
Okay, at least you heard it.
Yeah.
You have the audio memory.
Yes.
Yeah, I am.
I actually switched careers because of it.
I didn't wanna be on movie sets
and like miss that first step
and I did, I got Olive's on video.
I was like, "I got it."
(Drew grunts)
(audience laughing)
It's like the Holy Grail.
Yeah, I don't, you know, I just,
I think the things I, funny enough, fear are
just making sure my kids can come
and talk to me about everything.
That is the hook for me, the brass ring
of how can I create these relationships with my kids
that they can turn to me and talk to me
about anything and everything?
Okay, let's move onto the second one.
All right.
How do you set
aside time for yourself?
Do you wake up earlier or do you make a schedule
so that you can find time?
Sometimes I'll stay up late to watch TV.
Every once in a while I'll catch a Sunday,
that's a miracle, and I'll grab that remote control
and I'll think of all the things I could do with my life
and I just sit there and binge watch television.
(audience laughing)
That sounds about typical
for a mom though.
Okay, good, okay.
I just didn't know if you had a secret.
No, I am trying to figure out what balance is
and I'm still working on it.
That's good advice, okay, last one.
Okay, I'm learning how to make sure everyone gets their
fair share of time with Selah.
Okay.
How do you balance
making sure everyone in your friends
and family group get enough time with your kids?
I mean, I think it's just, honestly, making plans.
Like, send out a group text,
maybe have a few people over at the same time.
Make a little bit of a festive moment out of it,
so you're not having to make 20 different one-on-ones.
Maybe group effort, have some snacks,
have some drinks, have you and your friends
and hanging out with Selah.
Like, kind of like an open house.
Make it really celebratory
and it's just more, the more the merrier.
And better time economics as well.
Okay, love that.
I'll say this.
As a mom, you wear your heart on your sleeve.
And I'll do everything I can
to be the best person I can for my kids.
They have inspired me.
(audience applauding)
As Selah will inspire you.
'Cause when it's just you, you can kinda stay a kid
and then you have a kid and it's your turn
to grow up in a weird way,
but I will say, growing up isn't overrated,
I really like it.
I really love being an adult.
I really like being an adult too.
Well, Mucci, I'm so glad you're back,
I love you, we don't do this show without you,
we never will, you're so invaluable.
And just in time for Mother's Day,
Jergens Skin Care is releasing a new limited edition perfume
that smells just like that iconic cherry almond scent
of their Original Scent moisturizer
and Megan and our entire studio audience are gonna go home
with one today, alongside of a $50 gift card
to Walgreens.
(audience cheering)
I can't wait to go to this.
And to find out how you can get a chance
to win a limited edition Jergens Original Scent perfume,
check out all the official Jergens Instagram,
Jergens US.
(upbeat music)